نعم اذن البنيه التحتيه لها دور كبير في
مدى صمود المباني وبالتالي تقليل الاضرار
نحن فعليا
ما عدا البيان الاولي تغيب عنا
التحديثات الرسميه عن عدد ضحايا هذا
الزلزال ولكن المعروف ومثل ما ذكرت وذكر
الكثير من الزملاء الصحفيين وشهود العيان
بان هذه المناطق هي مناطق بالفعل نائيه هي
عباره عن قرى
بطرقات واعره وهذا ما ربما يصعب رصد ما
الذي احدثه الزلزال خلال هذه الساعات
الاولى لو نعود الى الطبيعه الزلزاليه من
حيث قوته من حيث ايضا
عمقه
وطبيعه المنطقه بشكل عام وقربها من
الصفائح التكتونيه
للقاره الاو روبيه والافريقيه في تقديرك
هذا الزلزال من اين جاءت قوته المدمره
اكثر من قوته او من طبيعته وعمقه
كلاهما ممكن تكون للاثنين يعني الطبيعه
والعمق وهذا الزلزال يبعد عن اطراف
الخزانه 500 كيلو هذا الزلزال يسمونه داخل
الصفيحه الافريقيه وفي خط
يمتد مثل ما ذكرت من اغادير الى الجزائر
في جبال الاطلس وهي جبال الاطلس داخل
الصفيحه الافريقيه ليس على اطراف كما
معتاد انه اغلب الزلاقه
الصفائح بين الصفيحه يعني مثلا بين
الصفيحه الافريقيه
والاوروبيه
فالزلزال هذا تاثيره اول شيء من اجل قوته
وضحالته الزلزال الضحل الطاقه تصل الى سطح
الارض باقل تمديد ما تبدد الزرزان عميق
تتبدد الطاقه بشكل
السيركل او بشكل كروم وتتبدل تمتصها تمتص
الطاقه داخل ارض لكن بما ان الزلزحل قوه
التدميريه او الابتزايه على السطح الارض
تكون اعلى من ما هو لو كانت زلزال عميق
والزلزال ايضا على يعني بكل المقاييس
وامتداد الصدا يعني ارتداد الصدعه الذي
حدث على الزلزال ممكن يكون ثلاثين الى 30
الى 40 كيلومتر على امتداد الصدع فهذا
الصدى عاده الجزائر تفكر فيه انه هو بؤره
وليس في وليس على الصدى الامتداد وله عرض
وامتداد هذا استطع ممكن يكون 30 الى 40
كيلو وايضا عرضه ممكن يشابه لها فهذا
سطح الفالق بالاضافه الى حاله العمق الى
قوه الزلزال يعطي القوه التدميريه للزلزال
مثل ما نويت انه القرى المتناثره التي
يصعب الوصول اليها ممكن يكون فيها تاثير
اكبر بكثير ما هو في المدن
اللي يمكن الوصول اليها عن طريق الاعلام
والسلطات المختصه
طيب ربما في هذه اللحظات ايضا اكثر ما
يتبادر الى الاذهان من تساؤلات خاصه من
اولئك الذين يسكنون في تلك المناطق هو
الهزات الارتداديه من خلال قراءتك
للزلازل الارتداديه والهزات التي وقعت عقب
هذا الزلزال الاول كيف يمكن متابعه نسقها
ما الذي يمكن قوله عنها
طبعا زلزال كبير مثل هذا الحجم لابد ان
يتبعه الدلاج الكثيره
تخف بالقوه مع الزمن لكن خلال 24 ساعه
اغلب علماء الزلازل وعلى الاغلب تكون
زلزال قمت بدرجه واحده من الزلزال الضخمه
خلال 24 ساعه ممكن يحدث ابعد من ذلك
بالزمن لكن الزلازل التوابع تستمر على
السطح على على نفس الصدى لانه الزلزال
كبير كبر يعني احنا نفكر بساطه هو السطح
الصدع هو السطح والحقيقه
ضخمه الزلزال كبير كسر اكبر نتوء على سطح
الفعل خاصه سطح الصدع
تتركز القوه على النتوءات الاخرى على هذا
الصدى فتتكسر تباعا منها نتوءات اكبر منها
اصغر حتى ترجع الطاقه الكامنه او المحدوده
في على هذا الصدى الى طبيعتها ما قبل
فتحدث زلازل الزلازل الاكبر تكون يعني
خلال الساعات الاولى بعد الزلزال الرئيسي
ومن ثم تتلاشى قواها الى ان تصبح صغيره
جدا لكن الزلازل الصغيره تحدث بالالاف عقد
مثل هذا الزلزال
اما تاثيرها يعني تاثيرها طبعا حسب مده
الاهتزاز يعني
والابنيه اذا كانت ايضا السقوط او اتعبه
الزلزال الاولي يعني الزلازل
الثانوي ممكن تكون مؤثره مثل الزلازل
الرئيسيه اذا كان المبنى
اهتز بشكل كبير خلال الهزه الرئيسي واصبح
ايضا فيمكن التاثيرات احيانا مثل الهزه
الرئيسيه او اكبر لانه المبنى تهالك
المبنى اصبح هاي السقوط اي دفعه اخرى او
استزاز اخر حتى لو كان مده اكثر ممكن يؤثر
عليه طيب وبالتالي هل هناك اي هامش زمني
تقديري يمكن لسلطات المختصه ان تضعه في
الحسبان وبالتالي
من هم خارج منازلهم يمكن ان يعودوا بعد
الاطمئنان على حاله تلك المنازل اولا
بالتاكيد
عاده تحتاج الى الى مهندسين يعني يشوفوا
المباني ويشوفوا مدى التشقق او او قدرتها
على الصمود لكن
الزلازل التاخير تبين انه خلال
48 ساعه الزلازل تتلاشى تصبح قواها اقل
فالسلطات المختصه ومجموعات المدين يجب ان
يقرروا انه هاي المبنى خاطر المباني
متاثره فيها الشقوق اذا الشقوق فقط بالجبس
والزركشه والزينه كل مبنى نستخدم مره اخرى
اذا كان الشقوق وتدخل في عناصر المبنى
الرئيسيه مثلا الخرسانه وغيرها فعندها
المهندس يقرر اذا كان المبنى يستخدم او لا
لكن خلال 24 الاسبوع الاول يجب ان يكون
المباني التي تاثرت يعني يكونوا في حذر
بعدها طبعا
لازم تفاجئ احيانا نتوقع شيء تاتي بشيء
اخر لكن
الدروس التاريخيه والتنازل المعروفه
الزلازل المؤثره يعني 48 الى اسبوع وبعدها
تتلاشى الزلازل قواها مع الزمن
واضح طيب في هذه المنطقه التي تصنف منطقه
زلزاليه حتى لو لم تضربها زلازل خلال
السنوات القليله الماضيه ولكن هي منطقه
زلزاليه معروفه بذلك ما هي الاجراءات التي
يجب ان تفرض على البناء
بناء
خاصه منطقه يعني ربما تاثير التربه
السطحيه لكن تاثير الطبوغرافيا التباين
الارتفاعات تباين الارتفاعات تؤثر على قوه
زلازل مثل
الزلازل يكون مؤثره اكبر او في السفوح
لانه في قيمه جبال تكون
او تجميع للطاقه تتناثر الابنيه
هناك في كل المناطق الزلزاليه ما يسمى او
ما يعرف بكود البناء المقاومه للزلازل في
معاملات تحسب ومحسوبه انا اعتقل المغرب
اذا بنيت المباني بمواصفات هندسيه مقاومه
للزلازل يعني ياتي الزلازل وتمرها على هذه
المباني ولا تؤثر على ربما تهتز وهذا شيء
طبيعي ما نحتاج الى المبنى يحتاج بس ما
ينكسر او ما يتاثر السكان فيه
الكود البناء المقاومه للزلازل في كل
البلدان المطبق عاده تكون خسائر الزلازل
قليله جدا ان لم تكن معدومه اما البلد لم
تطبق هذا الكود او المعايير المقاومه
للزلازل فتكون
التاثيرات على البنيه التحتيه والسكان
اكبر بكثير مما هو عليه او يجب ان يكون
عليه